dans quelles conditions l'activité et la
vie quotidienne des français vont
redémarrer à partir du 11 mai c'est la
question à laquelle devra répondre le
plan de déconfinement présenté cet après
midi à l'assemblée nationale par edouard
philippe
s'en suivra ensuite un débat et un vote
malgré les protestations de partis
d'opposition
ils se sont en effet insurgé contre le
manque de temps imparti entre la
présentation le débat et le vote qui se
succéderont donc en quelques heures des
travaux en format restreint pour assurer
le respect des règles sanitaires 75
députés devraient être présents sur les
577 que compte l'hémicycle avec une
répartition proportionnelle en fonction
de l'effectif des groupes parlementaires
relancer l'économie sans relancer
l'épidémie c'est la lourde tâche à
laquelle va devoir s'atteler le
gouvernement
le tout dans un contexte de défiance
d'après un récent sondage ifop pour le
jdd elle les français ne sont que 39% à
lui faire confiance pour faire face
efficacement aux coronavirus